aber park ba ba ba ba
hallo leute ich es wieder einmal warum
bekommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt sauer met your mother ist neben
scrubs die serie die ich als
jugendlicher am allermeisten geschaut
habe eigentliches prosieben dran schuld
weil sie die folgen immer und immer und
immer und immer wieder wiederholt haben
und es war auch egal zu welcher
tageszeit ich nach hause kam
es liegt immer mit dem auto um 17 uhr
dann oft haft ich habe manche folgen
echt 20 mal gesehen und als ich diesen
kommentar gelesen habe dachte ich ja
warum mache ich nicht den sieben
schichten salat aus how i met your
mother davon habe ich schon immer
geträumt wie schmeckt literweise
mayonnaise mit irgendwelchen komischen
zutaten und ich war ja nicht ich ne wenn
ich nicht so ein gefäß besorgt hätte wie
sie das in der serie haben wenn ihr auch
so auch wie ich habe mit dem abgeschaut
ob du bist jetzt ganz genau welchen
salat ich meine das ist der salat in
lili machen soll nachdem familienrezept
von den ericsson als marshall und lily
die familie besucht haben in minnesota
ich weiß noch diese ganzen sachen das
war auch das einzige rezept was ihr auch
gar nicht und nachschauen ist oder ob
ich mich gar nicht so jetzt belegen
musste wo kommt das vorlesen alles hier
ein gespeichert da so ein bisschen
nochma täterin und der andere teil ist
so hauer mit yo mama infos und
fahrradfahren das verlernt man nicht
das ist ein simpler schicht salat und
ich habe im internet auch ein foto
gefunden so sieht das aus und wir
brauchen einen salatkopf auch bacon
geraten keller roth zwiebelringe was
habt ihr da hinter eurem ohr chips und
drei liter mayonnaise das rezept ist
eine super einfach wir müssen alles
klein schneiden und echt lustige story
ich war mladen und habe mich gefragt was
möglich ist
mir gefällt das ist ja mirakel wird und
dann ist mir aufgefallen warum sagen wir
mirakel wirkt wenn es michael hipp ist
keine ahnung ist merkel okay der war
schlecht unsere erste schicht ist salat
und ich habe mir ein messer für 30 euro
gekauft was super scharfes und mit dem
super viel spaß macht zwischen ranger
plastik let's putz bau dieses messer so
scharf ich schneide mir locker die
finger rinnt in den medien hype unsere
erste schicht amtszeit des reichen oder
getröstet reusch und jetzt ein glas
mayonnaise dann mal rein damit
[Musik]
ich glaube das wird das ekligste sich
jedes menschen gemachte und jetzt folgt
unser bay bay
welcher wein ist euer lieblings
charakter
ich glaube meine war marshall rallye als
top marshall marcel baumann kriegs
charakter noch mehr wie das lecker aus
oder kriege ich schon richtig hunger
weiter geht's mit
ich muss aber sagen sind sehr was von
basteln was ihr wollt noch mich an
meiner seite habe ich komplett verpackt
aber die seite sieht gut aus jetzt
kommen wir ein bisschen
weihnachtsstimmung denn wir müssen
rotkohl schneiden
ich habe noch niemand den rotkohl
geschnitten muss ich zugeben diese außen
blätter sehen nicht so schön bei euch so
dieses leben war schmeckt ich hab echt
einfach ist das ding runter fällt
[Musik]
rot ist so schön schöner als mein
gesicht ok und jetzt in scheibchen
schneiden rotkohl ist so schön ist she
lovely sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
damen so die kleine frau rotkohl wurde
zerkleinert jetzt kommt sie in den topf
auf jeden fall jetzt mal was gesundes
das für nicht gut
bio ist für mich abfall 100 mal dürft
ihr raten was als nächstes kommt richtig
beraten
es ist so unspektakulär vom zuschauen
wie next one
sie bringen ein für mich und ein für
dich und mayonnaise
wir haben gleich fünf gekillt träumen
gar nicht was freue ich mich schon auf
die diskussion in den kommentaren das
was ja nicht vegetarisch ist und weiß
leute ich weiß dass sie so pervers
auflockern finally die letzte schicht
heimhilfe und glas nummer 6
[Musik]
leck mich sieht das geil aus dem wo mein
gott es ist schwer in coerde sind
einfach drei kilometer drin sind auf
jeden fall aus wie das original hier
nochmal zum vergleich definitiv ich habe
allerdings keine ahnung wie man das
jetzt serviert am besten in einer
schüssel schüsse schüsse schüssel ja
jetzt stellen wir uns wieder natürlich
der allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
der sieben schichten salat aus how i met
your mother ein schönes gummibärchen
rotkohl zwiebelringen ja klar wiese oder
ja wir können den käse gegessen
das ist mit abstand das ekligste was ich
jemals gegessen habt ok beschreibt euch
mal warum es so eklig ist gummibärchen
konsistenz chips konsistenz kohl
konsistenz drei verschiedenen
konsistenzen die alle zusammen no way
dann kommt noch die mayonnaise dazu die
einfach den kompletten geschmack
übernimmt und dann schmeckst du so ein
bisschen erdbeere von dem gummibärchen
und so ein bisschen chips geschmack und
so ein bisschen cool und du denkst dir
so das nächste wie schmeckt muss wieder
was richtig leckeres ich hoffe natürlich
wie immer euch das video gefallen und
wenn ja dann zeigt es mir mit einem
daumen nach oben und wenn ihr weitere
rezeptvorschläge habt aus filmen oder
serien eurer lieblings kinderserie
vielleicht oder das was ihr nach der
schule immer geschaut habt dann ab in
die kommentare damit ich lese es und
dann wäre es vielleicht nachkommen
wer weiß und hier sind weitere videos
abonnieren nicht vergessen
schon diese choreographie und die glocke
aktivieren wenn ihr kein neues video
verlassen wollte ich glaube ich kann es
heute ist